corona hammer aus baden württemberg
knallhart ministerpräsident winfried
kretschmann lebt lockerung bis ostern ab
er sieht im mindestens bis mitte april
keine chance für das ende von corona
beschränkungen eine debatte über exit
strategien vor ostern sehr er überhaupt
nicht das sagte der regierungschef am
dienstag in stuttgart wir brechen keine
debatte über exit-strategien vom zaun
das wäre völlig unangemessen und das
völlig falsche signal
das ländle hält also weiterhin an den
bestehenden corona maßnahmen fest ein
ende der regeln oder masken pflicht wie
in dänemark oder großbritannien ist noch
lange nicht in sicht
er und darüber waren wir sprechen mit
julius böhm aus der bild
politikredaktion guten tag julius was
sagst du zu den äußerungen von winfried
kretschmann ja es ist fast schon totaler
wahnsinn in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vor einer
woche hat man sich darauf verständigt
öffnungs perspektiven zu entwickeln
sobald feststeht dass die krankenhäuser
nicht mehr überlastet werden die ersten
politiker auch in der ampel haben sich
nach vorne gewagt selbst karl lauterbach
hat für mitte februar anfang märz gesagt
dann können wir über die erste
lockerungen sprechen uns gedanken machen
ist jedenfalls mal vorbereiten und in
all diese leichte vorsichtige positive
verlauf machen sage ich mal haut jetzt
der baden-württembergische präsident
rein und sagt nein nein wir müssen
mindestens bis ostern geschlossen halten
das enttäuschte stimmen viele menschen
die sich auf diese perspektive diese
positive perspektive gefreut hatten und
er bezieht sich dabei eben auch wieder
auf zahlen auf intelligenzen du hast ein
problem mit der intelligenz warum er
nicht richtig klappt wie bei bild so
ziemlich alle die inzidenz ist ja ein
wert der nicht erst seit kurzem
eigentlich
überfällig ausgelaufen nicht mehr so
relevant ist weil was sagt uns die
inzidenz wir schreiben jeden tag neue
rekorde heute 1200 unten etwas und
niemand weiß mehr was es überhaupt
bedeutet weil das bedeutet 1000 zweiter
instanz die für die menschen werden
krank wie viele sterben am ende parallel
dazu steigt eine impfquote die menschen
wiederum schützt parallel infizieren
sich menschen die wir gar nicht erkennen
weil die test kapazitäten ausgeschöpft
sind die dunkelziffer ist höher als
früher das heißt die inzidenz ist gar
nicht mehr gar nicht die zahl wert
dieser am ende ausdrückt totale
unklarheit und deswegen sollten wir
nicht in jeder medienmeldungen diese
zahl morgen im radio als erstes nennen
sollte die inzidenz deiner meinung nach
komplett abgeschafft werden komplett
abgeschafft werden ist gefährlich denn
sie ist sozusagen der wert der als
allererstes zeigt wie ist die dynamik
wie es die entwicklung der korona
infektion also man kann daran gut
erkennen wie sich die kurve quasi
entwickeln ob sich die verbreitung im
aufbau befindet oder eben im abbau aber
sie sollte nicht mehr der wichtigste
wert sondern nicht mehr der wert der als
erstes genannt wird sondern viel
entscheidender ist wie es die
krankheitslast der bevölkerung also wie
viele menschen werden am ende schwer
krank müssen im krankenhaus behandelt
werden und führe möglicherweise zu einer
belastung oder überlastung des systems
was glaubst du warum trotzdem einige
politiker sich irgendwie von diesem
incidents werden nicht verabschieden
wollen und dadurch krampfhaft run weiter
festhalten obwohl wir ja eben wie du ja
auch sagt inzwischen ganz andere werte
haben mit denen wir arbeiten können die
korona krise ist ja am ende des tages
eine medizinische eine wissenschafts
krise und wissenschaftskommunikation
haben wir alle gelernt ist hoch
kompliziert und nicht so einfach und
diesen wert haben die menschen einfach
gelernt jeder kennt die inzidenz wir
wussten irgendwann mal die grenzen x 35
x 50 dann war bei 100 die notbremse
inzwischen sie bei 1200 niemand weiß was
es bedeutet also was die auswirkungen
ist aber jeder kennt die jetzt denn ich
glaube da halten sich politiker gerne
daran fest und wie gesagt die inzidenz
ist das erste nach 56 tagen momente um
die dynamik zu beschreiben auch das
könnte ein grund sein daran festzuhalten
aber wie gesagt selbst der lkw chef
lothar wieder hat gesagt wir müssen uns
die krankheitslast anschauen und die
inzidenz immer weiter in den hintergrund
rücken lassen und so sollte jetzt sowohl
von medien also von politikern in
zukunft auch gehandelt werden eine ganz
kleine nachfrage hätte ich noch berlin
hat sich jetzt entschlossen die kontakt
verfolgung einzustellen da kann man ja
dann eigentlich nur noch von resignation
sprechen oder ist das tatsächlich dann
jetzt auch der richtige weg wo man sagen
kann gut brauchen wir auch eigentlich
nicht mehr wenn wir konsequenter weise
sagen die inzidenz ist nicht mehr der
entscheidende wert dann ist es auch
konsequent nicht mehr die kontakt
nachverfolgung so sehr nach zu ziehen
dann auch nicht mehr jeden mit pcs
beispielsweise zu testen denn wenn wir
den fokus darauf setzen die menschen die
wirklich schwer erkranken können und
daran sterben können ältere vor
erkrankte und so weiter und eben die
menschen den krankenhäusern kliniken
arbeiten zu schützen dann kann man
theoretisch auch die kontakt
nachverfolgung runterfahren und eben
diese deutlich weniger gefährliche
mikrowelle den jungen menschen den
geimpften menschen
die damit konfrontieren weil die gefahr
dass da jemand schwer erkrankt ist
wirklich inzwischen sehr sehr sehr
gering sagt julius blum aus der bild
politikredaktion vielen dank danke dir